[Music]
so
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning from buildback beaver to john
von goevey boris johnson's closing
remarks at the conservative party
conference yesterday were full of gags
and plenty of optimism to keep the tory
faithful smiling
just how much substance was there in his
speech and did the prime minister come
across as a statesman or simply a
showman we'll be asking his colleague
the education secretary nadeem sahibwi
in just a couple of minutes time
also this morning the campaign to stop
violence against women i'll be speaking
to refuge ambassador and comedian joe
brand as demonstrations take place
outside new scotland yards to call for
action after the murder of sarah everard
and ahead of international dave the girl
on monday i'll be speaking to the author
candice carty williams about her new
novel delving into the lives of two
teenage girls from different backgrounds
growing up in london it is thursday the
7th of october
and that's all folks
optimism abounds in the prime minister's
closing conference speech
but fears for the immediate presence as
prices rise and benefits fall
a breakthrough for science the world's
first malaria vaccine could be rolled
out to billions
i'm live in kisumu in kenya where the
world's first malaria vaccine is being
rolled out potentially saving tens of
thousands of lives
turmoil in texas a federal judge orders
the state to suspend its new law banning
most abortions
the rising cost of living a warning that
council tax may have to increase by up
to five percent a year for the next
three years
a powerful earthquake hits pakistan at
least 20 are dead more than 200 injured
a haven for the homeless our
double-decker buses are becoming a
welcome stop for rough sleepers
as for the weather warmer and mostly
fine in the east cloudy with rain in the
northwest
[Music]
morning all the prime minister closed
the conservative party conference with a
characteristically upbeat speech
pledging a bold gutsy program of reform
for the country but for all the talk of
a brighter more prosperous future
there are many who feel we didn't
perhaps hear so much about the issues of
the now rising prices a persistent
supply crisis and fears of a pretty
bleak winter ahead all that against the
backdrop of the cut to the universal
credit uplift coming into effect for but
millions of lower income households
um let's take a quick look at the
reception the speech has received and i
think it's fair to say that it has been
somewhat mixed in the papers this
morning uh here's the guardian its
headline vacuous and bombastic uh
quoting at the adam smith institute
there
also the ratings from pro brexit
business leaders on the front page of
the times they say they're being treated
like sponges soaking up the rising costs
questions from up north as well the
yorkshire post asking where's the detail
they report disappointment at the lack
of any plan for regional rail
but it certainly wasn't all bad the
telegraph leads on the pledge to protect
green areas from new housing which they
expect will please many conservative
voters
and i think it's pretty clear to see
what the express made of it they thought
that iron man boris was kidnapping that
delivered a barnstorming performance
from the prime minister are packed with
energy and ambition
uh well let's bring in our correspondent
ali fortes good morning ali um look
we've gone through the papers there and
it's clear there's a there is a range of
views on the prime minister's speech
perhaps as much as anything else it was
a speech to the conference hall
as the country yeah that's right i mean
as you say you know you only need to
look at the papers to see if there has
been a frosty response from many
businesses but yes that's right it was
went down really well in the
conservative conference hall this was an
auditorium specially built for boris
johnson he has a very secure position
right now in the party and it was a very
johnson speech if you like lots of
slogans lots of laughs but less in the
way of policy and there is this tension
between what's going on in the
conservative conference or what's going
on in the outside world there are these
concerns about the supply chains that
are very real about labor shortages
about high gas prices high fuel prices
and i think his optimism did jar with
many businesses and many voters at home
as well and
certainly the the sense that you get
from businesses they do feel slightly
like they have been abandoned by a party
that's meant to be the party of business
he says this is about moving to a
high-wage high productivity economy he
wants to make this an argument about
immigration about not pulling the lever
on uncontrolled immigration but i think
it's a gamble as to whether people that
will push people away certainly in the
short short term if we get to a very
difficult winter i have listened to
torsten bell here from the resolution
foundation
the policy choices they're making are
making that costly living crunch
particularly bad for low income
households because for them not only are
their prices and bills going up but
their incomes are actually coming down
they're coming down a lot i mean we're
talking about 1 million households
losing 10 percent of their disposable
incomes these are huge effects for some
households and they will be much bigger
than for example the effects of the
national insurance rise that the
population as a whole will feel in
april next year and actually they'll be
bigger than the energy price rises that
everybody's feeling so we've got costs
going up for everybody and we've got
incomes coming down for the kind of
bottom four million households in the
country in terms of their income so that
is a really worrying thing to see
uh so let's try and put some metrics in
all of this some polling has been done
comparing the pm and the leader of the
opposition yeah that's right so this is
exclusive polling from opinion for sky
and as you said compared kirstarma the
labour leader with boris johnson kirsten
speech last week it asked
1305 people what they thought of those
two speeches looking at different
snippets from it and it asked them where
they agreed with the content on that 51
agreed with the pro uh prime minister
but it was higher for kierstarma 63 said
they agreed with kirstama on whether
each leader came across as strong uh
kyocerma again came out on top with 57
compared with 53 percent for johnson and
when it comes to how competent each
leader seemed the prime minister scored
49 percent whereas kirstama polled at 62
but the biggest disparity in the polling
came on the question of whether each
leader seemed like they cared about
ordinary people just under 70 percent
thought stammer did whereas under half
thought that the prime minister did and
we know that boris johnson does care
about these sorts of polls so he may not
be particularly pleased with the news
across all of the metrics here kirstama
seems to have fare better
ali thanks very much indeed
and by the magic of television the
education secretary nadeem's army joins
us in the studio minister good to see
you and of course congratulations on the
new job but but let's dwell on on what
we heard and he did what we didn't hear
from the prime minister yesterday was it
a mistake for boris johnson not to
mention in his speech three of the big
live issues for the country at the
moment supply shortages petrol cues and
the biggest overnight cutting benefits
that we have ever seen
well i think what he did talk about is
skill skill skills which is very much
my department department of education he
spoke about the leveling up of
opportunity we've announced a 3 000
pound
effectively bonus to um early teaching
candidates who we can retain
in years one to five and hopefully in
those areas of the country that the
children need the most
um we
announce half a billion pounds to help
those who will find it most difficult
with their fuel bills with the utility
bills because of the gas price increase
that's obviously global because the
global economy is rebounding um that was
all during party conference or the
beginning of party conference sure sure
but but these these are issues that have
been on the front page of every
newspaper for for weeks now and the
prime minister pointedly didn't mention
that the day after a prime minister's
speech to party conference we generally
have page after page of analysis in the
newspapers of the policy announcements
that are made instead we have page after
page of the jokes
that he made
it's worth remembering
that literally
a few weeks before party conference
he announced probably the biggest and
most important uh policy that successive
governments including conservative
governments i have to say were unable to
deal with or deliver which is adult
social care 36 billion pounds going into
fixing
and that was a massive announcement i'm
sorry i'm sorry minister but we're
talking about the speech yesterday i
hear you i'm just i'm just saying put it
in perspective right only only
literally few weeks before party
conference
we announced what is i think an
extraordinary achievement by a prime
minister
ever since i joined the conservative
party success of governments labor and
conservatives
and they're never dealt with i
understand this but there is more than a
degree of frustration particularly
amongst people who are working looking
for work but on universal credit that he
didn't mention it it was as i mentioned
the single biggest cut to welfare that
we have seen in this country and he
couldn't be bothered to mention it as we
enter into colder winter with fuel
prices rising with food prices rising
you know and with well with jobs let's
just say for some people at a premium
and it's really important to remember
that
as we
arrived in manchester we announced half
a billion pounds for winter for those
families that will find it most
difficult on their fuel bills on their
utility bills
according to the gatum institute 840 000
people including almost 300 000 children
are going to be pushed into poverty as a
result of the universal credit uplift
ending and he didn't mention i'm asking
the question again that i started with
why didn't he why did he choose to skirt
the biggest political issues of the day
well this is why i would respectfully
disagree because one we announced
literally as we were arriving in
manchester half a billion pounds for
those families for this winter on by the
way on top of the
winter fuel allowance the warm homes got
all the things for the most vulnerable
families to be able to help them over
winter months the 20 pounds uplift was
always temporary now
it was an important part of the 400
billion it was about 9 billion of the
400 billion that
rishi sunak wrapped his arms around the
people who are most vulnerable on the
lowest pay
many of them on universal credit through
the pandemic but as we come out the
other end where we're seeing
jobs
market being incredibly dynamic there's
two million fewer
people out of work today than forecasts
through the four million households with
3.3 million children seeing their
incomes drop by more than a thousand
pounds and the prime minister can't be
bothered to mention it the reason i keep
pushing on this point the reason i keep
pushing on this point is it has felt it
points during this party conference that
the conservatives have been you know
somewhat out of touch i mean you had uh
therese coffee you know
singing along you know on the at the
point at which the universal credit
uplift was removed singing along at a
karaoke event you've got another
colleague peter bottomley talking about
the grim struggle of living on an mp's
82 000 pounds a year salary i mean where
is the connection to people who are
struggling at the moment whereas the we
had plenty of jokes from the prime
minister yesterday but where was he when
when some people wanted him to reach out
to the poorest and some of the hardest
working people in this country and
reassure them that everything is going
to be okay and he glossed over it
so where i'm
slightly hoping that as well as quoting
things like the 20 pound uplift you
would also quote the national living
wage has delivered 4 000 pounds more
into people's uh pay packets uh because
of what boris johnson could have made an
announcement on raising minimum wage
yesterday
but that's done in you know there's a
there's a process to that indeed but
you didn't mention the half a billion
which we announced as we arrived in
manchester for those same vulnerable
families that will be delivered by their
local councils because they're the ones
who know them best for their for their
fuel bills for their utility bills and
for their food needs that's the same
people who may fall through the safety
net now
lots of other people
my job is to skill them up skill we've
got a lifetime skills guarantee that
when i was
there's the apprenticeship tsar in the
coalition government
if you told me there'd be a prime
minister who will offer people at any
age the ability to pull off modules to
reskill an upskill and we would back
them i'd have bitten your arm off this
prime minister delivered that but with
that czar's hat on look at the papers
this morning and look at the reaction
from the business community who to a
greater or lesser extent feel that the
conservatives are not the party of
business anymore i mean the boss of
iceland himself a committed brexiteer
says he's been warning for labor about
labor shortages for months with
absolutely no response from the
government you know the adam smith
institute described the rhetoric from
the prime minister yesterday as
economically illiterate we heard from
the conservative think tank bright blue
the public will assume tired of boris's
banter if the government does not get a
grip of mounting crisis the polling that
we have done shows that his speech
outside the conference hall was less
well received than that of kier starmer
why is this party a party that has long
held its business credentials up as a
reason to vote for it on a war path with
business at the moment well i don't
agree with you the first thing i would
say is we are the party i haven't made
these i'm not saying no you haven't let
me just give you yeah
my side of this i met with the cbi tony
danker and karen balamori
and we all agree
that actually
the the look at what we've done on um
seasonal workers increased the number by
five thousand eight gb drivers increase
the visa numbers by five thousand but
that
visa bit is not the answer the long-term
answer the long-term answer is you work
with business
let me try and bring it to life for you
in the food industry i went to wilmore
which is in my constituents one of the
biggest suppliers of fresh food and veg
to the supermarkets i said how are you
doing they said we're doing well yes
there are pressures because of all the
issues that you've just described but
because of rishi sunax
tax break for us to invest in equipment
we can get 25 of that back we're
investing in equipment and and hold on
and upskilling
and
reskilling and increasing the wages of
our people because they're going to have
to work with automation and by way of
contrast the federation of bulk small
businesses says it's equally remarkable
to hear the benefits of a low tax
economy volunteered when the government
has just signed off a hike in national
insurance contributions which we
estimate will cost at least 50 000 jobs
so what i would say to everybody is look
let's work together we we've seen
retailers who've invested in technology
and have done really well others like
topshop and topman didn't make that
investment and haven't done so well
we've seen smes take advantage 100
billion pounds of grants and loans to
support smes that is what this
government is doing to help business
let's do this together let's produce
that high-wage high school economy
because it is doable let's talk then on
on your briefing there was a policy
exchange event that you spoke at on on
sunday in the fringe of the conference
you were asked whether or not you
planned to get school children to wear
masks you said we have got contingency
plans in the department if we see
further disruption do those contingency
plans include a return to children
wearing masks perhaps even a return to
bubbles
so the good news is that and thanks to
the brilliant teachers and support staff
and parents and and children 99 of
schools are open attendance has gone up
the last set of figures i looked at was
about 90 percent um that obviously will
will will fluctuate depending on
infection rates yeah but the the
my priority is to protect education keep
those schools open rachel de souza the
children's commissioner had a 500 000
survey of of children
at school 200 2 and a half thousand
children of gypsy and roma families yep
16 000 of scnd they all said they want
to be back at school this is they value
that interaction with them come on tell
me so we have the bubbles right so we've
got a contingency plan
as you would expect me to do as
especially in the vaccines minister does
it continue it contains lots of lots of
consistency including masks yeah
absolutely but at the moment at the
moment i don't want to return to bubbles
because actually you saw the other
fall-off in attendance which really does
harm mental well-being mental health for
children you saw in richard this is a
survey and i don't want to return to
that and my priorities to protect
education and keep schools open and
children at school we're all very fond
of recycling these days no more so than
yourself with this 3 000 pounds up list
for teachers this was a policy that was
benned a couple of years ago
it's a policy that worked this is
different and better because the
teachers have been eligible for five
years um to be able to to
take advantage of that up to three
thousand pounds
if they stay in the profession in maths
in chemistry in computing in physics in
the schools that most need them sure
just on ventilation though where are we
in terms of the pilot programs they're
getting the co2 monitors into schools
and possibly we're getting to a stage
where schools can't simply have the
windows open anymore so what are we
doing about that so we're getting 300
000 co2 monitors into schools the last
time your predecessor spoke there he
talked to me about that yeah have we not
made any progress no we have we have
absolutely
they're going out by the end of this
month we would have
the real uplift in those
numbers into schools really important
we're also looking at ventilation and
how we
make sure that schools have access to uh
ventilation how can they do that how
much there's lots of there's lots of
technology
but how might you
ease their access to that technology
we're talking about kind of the central
government buying it are we talking
about grants being given to schools so
i'm looking to buy a quantity and then
also create a market
that schools can access if they need
them excellent very very briefly on your
old brief um the vaccines minister story
that appeared yesterday did france
really steal 5000 dorsis of the visor
vaccine from us i can't possibly comment
yes you can
look
we you know we we had a a challenging um
uh uh
situation with the eu commission uh we
always took the view that um we don't
block any exports of any vaccines from
the uk the way we got our vaccines
through
having good contracts and cake bingham
to do brilliant jobs as the vaccines
task force as a whole
in delivering those contracts and you
know the eu commission worked with us on
making sure our supplies from uh belgium
fires and elsewhere worked well and of
course
we did everything we can to help france
and other countries as well uh website
minister good to see you this morning
thanks for being with us thank you
still to come on the program this
morning at five past eight we head to
the other side of the chamber to find
out what labour made of the prime
minister's conference speech at the
shadow child poverty secretary west
street
then at a quarter past eight i'll be
speaking to the comedian joe brandt
we'll be joining domestic abuse charity
refuge at new scotland yard today
protesting against violence by police
officers on women
at quarter tonight i'll be speaking to a
member of the parachute regiment on what
leadership in the army really means
it has been called historic the first
vaccine against malaria could be rolled
out to billions of people saving tens of
thousands of lives every year the
breakthrough ends a 100-year quest to
find a jab for one of africa's biggest
killers one of the worst affected
countries is kenya
around 70
of the population there is at risk from
malaria
there are an estimated three and a half
million new clinical cases
and 10
700 deaths each year
more than a third of households don't
have access to nets treated with
insecticide
we visited kenya to find out the scale
of the problem there sky's health
correspondent ashish joshi is in kizumu
for us this morning
ashish
you'll correct my pronunciation i am
sure but this truly is a a breakthrough
moment for africa in dealing with
vaccine
[Music]
i'm here in the kisumu county hospital
where the mother and baby clinic is well
underway and you can see all of these
mothers here with their very young
children with their babies coming along
for their regular health checks and
that's why
this malaria vaccine the first of its
kind
is so important because it can be
incorporated into the children's
immunization program they come here when
they're six months old they come back
when they're eight nine and then the
fourth dose at 24 and it gives them
protection we've seen the impact this
vaccine is having on this region where
malaria is endemic the children's ward
which might normally be full of very
sick or even dying children is
practically empty there were three
children in there yesterday they are all
very close to being discharged
we have here mother naomi and her son
ruel
ruel is about to have his fourth dose of
the vaccine he doesn't know that yet but
i'll let the nurse administer his
vaccine but let me tell you just what an
impact this vaccine is having here this
is an area where the world health
organization
decided to use as a pilot to see how
effective this gsk vaccine would be the
rts s
it is having
a major impact let's talk
to
naomi now she's consoling luelle who's
had
his injection
[Music]
oh
he's a brave little boy he's a brave
little boy
oh sorry royale
me this is his fourth injection you must
be very pleased that your son is now
vaccinated against malaria
what does it mean to you
it means that you will not have malaria
you know this area has a male pandemic
area
the take up of the malaria vaccine is
very high 80 or 90 in this region
parents want their children to be
vaccinated don't they yeah
they do
and that's one of the successes of the
pilot program is the take up 80 or 90
percent people here african parents want
their children to be vaccinated because
they know this does offer them a future
free from a killer disease
i think actually i think parents up and
down the country just shared the pain of
that mother there we've all had to take
them for vaccinations and we know how it
can be at this however a fantastic story
we'll speak again throughout the morning
for now ashish thanks very much indeed
and now a federal judge in texas has
suspended a new law in the state banning
abortions after the six-week mark
the so-called heartbeat bill is the most
restrictive abortion law in the united
states uh let's speak to our u.s
correspondent greg miller who's joining
us now
morning greg just explain exactly what
has happened in terms of this legal
process for for such a seismic decision
by the state legislature to be
overturned
yeah and this is the first uh legal
victory for those who are opposed to
this law a judge in texas uh suspended
enforcement of that uh that new law
while lots of legal challenges go
through he said it denies women their
constitutional rights because having an
abortion is legal under u.s law he
called it an offensive deprivation of
those constitutional rights
and at the attorney general the white
house have all welcomed that decision it
might be short-lived because texas has
already within hours has filed an appeal
against that decision and they filed
that appeal to a court that has already
uphold upheld the right to put that law
into place so this this decision is
likely to be overturned in the next few
days and abortion providers probably
weren't going to resume their work
because they still fear uh being
prosecuted but this is the most
restrictive law in the us and what's
extraordinary about it is it gives
private citizens the right to bring
these prosecutions not prosecutors
they private citizens bring these
prosecutions and can win damages against
abortion providers those who aid or abet
abortions as it's described they can win
damages of ten thousand dollars it's
been described as a bounty vigilante uh
justice it's already had an impact
in the numbers of people being seen at
abortion clinics in texas down 80
percent in the first few weeks of this
law and a surge at clinics in
neighboring states like
oklahoma it's a massive cultural issue
we saw at the weekend a massive women's
number of women's marches across the
united states opposing laws like this
and there are lots more in the works in
other republican states so it will end
up at the supreme court but there are
lots of twists and turns on the way
there
certainly were greg many thanks indeed
now an influential think tank has warned
that council tax might need to rise by
up to five percent annually
for the next three years uh let's bring
in uh sky's laura bunda who's in the
newsroom been taking a closer look at
this explain exactly how they've arrived
at this figure laura
you know we've been looking at funding
levels and making predictions based on
the amount of money councils will need
once you factor in everything
and the conclusion basically from those
researchers at the ifs is that
if you take into account that five
percent tax hike then that will mean all
of us on average will be paying an extra
220 pounds a year within the next three
years the researchers say that just to
keep local council services running at
pre-pandemic levels their council tax
bills will need to go up by 3.6 but take
into account extra costs and the aging
population we have and that's where they
come to this 5
figure they're also looking at the
government's long-awaited reforms to
social care and say that they're
actually going to cost five billion
pounds which is nearly treble the amount
that's been allocated for and it's not
just a question of the cost it's also
about where the money will be spent the
researchers say that the local
government funding system is hopelessly
out of date and unfair now the
government says uh the government's
allocated more than 12 billion pounds
directly to council since the start of
the pandemic with more than six billion
available to spend as they see fit uh
but the ifs is predicting if the
councils don't get billions more than
they could be faced with having to cut
services
i certainly could uh laura for now
thanks very much indeed uh let's take
you through a few of the other stories
uh making the news this morning
and at least 200 people have been killed
and more than 200 injured after an
earthquake in central pakistan the 5.7
magnitude quake struck close to the city
of quetta near the border with
afghanistan
local authorities say more than a
hundred houses have collapsed and a
large number of buildings were also
damaged
a judge in the united states has agreed
for the duke of york's lawyers to
receive a copy of a 2009 settlement that
they believe will nullify the civil
sexual assault case
andrew b brettler who represents prince
andrew had argued at a previous hearing
that virginia dufrey who's uh suing the
queen's son for alleged sexual assault
had entered into a settlement agreement
that would end her current lawsuit
prince andrew has denied all the
allegations
a brighton hove albion footballer has
been arrested on suspicion of sexual
assault the player who can't be named
for legal reasons is one of two people
taken into custody following the
incident in the early hours of wednesday
morning
in a statement the club says that it's
aware that one of its players is
assisting police with the investigation
of an alleged offence the matter is
subject to a legal process and the club
therefore unable to make further comment
at this time
edging towards the weekend let's see how
the weather is looking and it is set to
turn warmer over the next few days but
it will be windy at times with rain in
the north and west at quite mild and
cloudy at the moment with hill fog and
patchy drizzle in the north and west and
heavier more general rain for many
northwestern parts
central and eastern england will remain
dry with sunny spells developing widely
through the morning elsewhere it'll stay
rather gray and damp without breaks of
sometimes heavy rain moving through the
northwest
still to come on the program i'll be
taking a quick look back at the highs
and lows of conference season with two
former political advisors
[Music]
welcome back the prime minister's
closing speech to the tory conference
yesterday was welcomed by delegates but
perhaps not so much uh by the world of
business a few minutes ago i put some of
their words to the education secretary
nadine zahawi and that's why the
so-called party of business seems to be
at odds with so many bosses
first thing i would say is we are the
party i haven't made these
no i you haven't let me just give you
my side of this i met with the cbi tony
danker and karen balamoria
and we all agree
that actually
look at what we've done on um seasonal
workers increased the number by five
thousand eight gb drivers increase the
visa numbers by five thousand
but that
visa bit is not the answer the long-term
answer the long-term answer is you work
with business
let's begin our correspondent ali
fortescue and ali look nadine zaha is a
man who knows a thing or two about
business he wasn't giving much away but
even he will know that that speech was
not necessarily particularly warmly
welcomed by a number of key figures in
that community absolutely i mean a
frosty response you need to look at the
front pages to see there's been a frosty
response from businesses the boss of
iceland who's a lead voter saying that
businesses are being treated like
sponges effectively suggesting that the
government are abandoning businesses and
you heard nadeem zahawi there talking
about the visa scheme for 500 drivers
there is a shortfall of a hundred
thousand hgv drivers so still long way
off and there's a very real concerns
around the supply chain around the labor
shortage and the prime minister talking
about this big economic shift towards a
high wage high productivity
system i think that has jarred with a
lot of businesses who think that he's
he's taking a real risk in the short
term and that we are heading towards a
very difficult winter and we're saying
too when he was talking about the
universal credit uplift he mentioned the
half a billion pounds that's been given
to councils that is significant but
that's going to be around 100 pounds per
person which isn't the same as 20 pounds
a week that came with the universal
credit
uh well ali for now thanks very much
indeed um uh well let's
then think about not just the
conservative party conference but of
course
labour and the rest of them at no
shortage of talking points to go through
with the observers chief leader writer
former adviser to ed miliband sonia soda
along with the former deputy head of
policy at number 10 under theresa may
now director of onwards will tana lovely
to see you both i do hope you're both
very well and not entirely fatigued at
the end of party conference season and
sonia to you first we'll deal with the
conservatives laterally because you know
our memories might might start might be
starting to stretch slightly of what
actually happened at the labour party
conference i i suspect that shakir
starmer will have left that feeling
relatively pleased
i think so i think there were a couple
of things uh that went well for him that
he will be pleased about so first of all
um you know this won't make much
difference to external perceptions of
the labour party
but kirstama did get through a package
of reforms quite internal facing reforms
that are actually pretty significant so
um they got through a reform that makes
it much harder for sitting mps to be
deselected by an unrepresented sort of
group of members in their local party
and mps have sort of said over the last
five years
how worried they've been about that
after rule changes that were brought in
by jeremy corbyn and the left of the
parties that might free those mps up a
bit um they've also increased the number
of mps that it takes for someone to get
on the member-wide ballot um to become
the next leader so essentially these are
reforms that are aimed at weakening the
left um further and making sure that
kirstama can put country in speaking to
the country before worrying about
internal factualism so they'll be
pleased about that i think starman will
also be quite pleased with how his
speech went down so you know i have to
say i think expectations were a bit low
going in
because he's not always the sort of most
charismatic of performers but it was it
was a really good speech and it shifted
stoma to talking about things that
really matter to people in the country
so not enough good schools in their uh
local area um you know it's really hard
at the moment to get any action if
you're a victim of crime because the
police are under resource the courts are
so underresourced so i think um i think
you know stalmer's team would have come
out of that conference feeling pretty
pleased it hasn't had much impact on on
poll ratings though it's a health
warning but we may not have really
experienced that to happen yet well
we'll see we'll see that things
sometimes take a little while to work
through the the pipe work but will i
mean would you would you agree with with
all of that i mean yeah cursed armor did
get some of his reforms through he
didn't get all of what he wanted to get
done at past conference he also managed
to lose a member of the shadow cabinet
at a time when you know plenty of people
were being rather more concerned not
about you know international warfare in
the labour party but about not being
able to get petrol at the pumps
well i think i think sonia is right in
some respects clearly this was a
conference where kirsten wanted to get
his house in order and he did i think
broadly succeed in doing so but the
central problem was that uh the visual
effect of that for people not at labour
party conference and not engrossed in
labour party detail is it looked like a
conference at which the factions of the
labour party were still battling amongst
themselves as he said we had a shadow
cabinet minister resign over the
proposed 15 pound minimum wage that
conference was voting on um and we had
uh lots of kind of briefing between
different elements uh of the shadow
cabinet including angela rayner uh and
her uh kind of accusation that tories
were scum so so it didn't look like a
particular particularly harmonious
conference and it also didn't centrally
addre address the central problem that
kiyosama has which is a failure to
connect with the british public and to
settle set out a narrative that
resonates with the british people he did
talk about some good things in his
speech as sonia said schools mental
health those were welcome policy
announcements but he hasn't yet found i
think that central message that is going
to win over all of those voters in the
former red wall uh that uh that labour
lost at the last election and unless he
addresses that it's all for nothing
um sonia let's move on to the
conservative party conference and i'm
gonna
stick my neck out here and say that
there's probably quite a bit that you
were not desperately pleased with but
just to compare and contrast between
what we saw at the labour conference i
mean
there wasn't much harmony on display at
the labour conference
surprisingly for a conservative party
conference for once you know
pretty much everyone was singing from
the same hymn sheet
yeah and i think that's a sign of where
we are in the parliament and the fact
that boris johnson two years ago um you
know delivered an 80-seat majority and
despite a whole load of things going
wrong for the government including um
the awful death toll that we've seen in
the pandemic and some really bad
mistakes that were made around care
homes including what's going on at the
moment with the fuel shortage forecast
rising fuel prices
you know the government really does seem
to be getting away with pushing the
blame for this stuff on other people
and um it hasn't dented johnson's poll
rating so i don't think it's a big
surprise uh that people were feeling
inclined to swing behind their leader at
tory conference you know you're always
going to have much more facialism in a
party that's in in opposition where
government still feels a long way off so
i wasn't too surprised uh by the
difference in feel really of the two
conferences in that sense
um well though let's focus on on the
concluding point of of the conservative
conference and indeed the conference
season itself the prime minister's
speech with nadim zahari on this morning
you know he talked a good game but
ultimately the party the conservative
party cannot rebut the fact that the
keynote address and then the speech of
the the speech of the conference season
the prime minister's address didn't deal
with supply shortages didn't deal with
you know labor shortages didn't deal
with the universal credit uplift being
rescinded
well look this was a speech from a party
leader to his party faithful it was a
general ruling his troops it was a prime
minister setting out his vision
for the parliament and i suspect uh
setting out a vision for the next
election as well so um
it wasn't an address to parliament it
wasn't uh a kind of detailed policy
announcement i think we need to avoid
assuming that it should be the latter
because ultimately this was the prime
minister talking to his party um but i
do think that the government does need
to worry about some of the things you
just mentioned the cost of living crisis
um
is a kind of a real risk for the
government and it needs to be incredibly
careful about not loading too many costs
onto voters at a very fragile point in
our economy um i think actually what the
government was trying to talk about at
conference this move to a high wage high
productivity high skill economy is the
right thing to do
um but in order to get there we're going
to need some detailed policy
announcements in the leveling up white
paper and the spending review in the
coming weeks and so the devil will be in
the detail it is coming it's coming in
the next month
and that's i think when we can really
judge the government uh on uh its plan
rather than the prime minister's address
which ultimately was always going to be
a running of the troops
but i'm just i'm just too impatient for
that well i'm just too impatient for
that guys i'm afraid we're going to have
to leave it there sonia soda will turn
lovely to see you both thanks for
joining us thank you
now two refurbed london buses are set to
begin offering help to homeless people
in the capital ahead of the winter
months
the double-deckers will be offering free
dental care gp consultations haircuts
therapy
and employment support as guys shinki
maruriki reports
one of london's most famous modes of
transport is getting a fresh lick of
paint
from today these two double-decker buses
will become havens for the homeless
providing them with vital skills and
services
from haircuts and shower facilities to
help opening bank accounts if they need
them
it's the brainchild of change please an
award-winning coffee shop and social
enterprise
the bus is a pragmatic way of providing
these services because
they are quite big they're double
deckers and it means that we can bring
those services directly to people who
need it the most our buses look the same
as
other normal london buses so it's it's
really trying to normalize the service
to make people feel comfortable
in our space
i've been through a lot and it's like i
mean a lot if we had two hours to i mean
that wouldn't even be long enough you
would be just
i mean i've been broken from front to
back and up and down and it's been bad
one person who has already seen their
life changed by the organization is
thomas noble
an ex-offender deported from the u.s he
arrived here with nothing before he
joined their training course becoming a
barista
you go into a gp or something and you're
off the street
as soon as you walk into a gp people are
going to look at you like
you know i mean and that's not a good
feeling for anybody there will be no
judgment
you step on that bus they got you
this used to be a standard london bus
but now it looks very different driving
for change is an initiative providing
dental services gp consultations therapy
and more its aim to support thousands of
people sleeping rough in london
the tools you have at your disposal you
know they're not great you've got a gel
you've got a mirror it's metal it's not
nice so you've got to do a lot of
emotional work and you've got to try and
make the space as nice as you can and
really try and connect with people
try and make sure that they feel they're
not being judged
when these vehicles hit the road they
won't just be brightening people's
smiles
they'll be helping them turn their lives
around one step at a time
shinki maori sky news
uh some interesting pictures to uh bring
you just a warning first though there is
some flash photography in that which we
are about to show you which is
the man with the golden
star uh daniel craig has been awarded a
star on the hollywood walk of fame can't
believe he hadn't had that already
actually uh following that his following
his final outing as james bond during
his acceptance speech he said that it's
been an absolute honour to be walked all
over in hollywood after having his star
on appropriately unveiled at a location
with double07 as its address uh the
actor is the 274th
recipient of the prestigious honor
joining the likes of fellow bond alumni
sean connery and sir roger moore let me
know why daniel craig is the best ever
bond on social why you're right and i'm
wrong uh in this break afterwards we
will be talking about the tensions
between china and taiwan they're
steadily increasing but what actually
does it mean for geopolitics we'll be
chatting to a foreign policy analyst
after this
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of people have
been displaced and are affected and most
of them of course are living in uh awful
uh conditions and hence the appeal from
iom the international organization for
migration um in respect of the types of
stories that we are hearing um from idps
as you can imagine as internally
displaced persons they've lost
absolutely everything having to flee
their homes and found themselves in
these unimaginable circumstances many of
them living
in dilapidated
settings
i was in tigre earlier this year and you
had thousands of people
living in schools disused buildings and
some sleeping out in the open and
exposed obviously to all the elements of
changing weather et cetera et cetera and
so the testimonies that we hear from the
idps are extremely uh difficult and sad
uh stories many of the settings in which
they are living in um can no longer be
sustained or the resources are running
out to maintain um those um settings so
for instance what you have is uh people
huddled in in in very small and cramped
place places um there is very little
access to water and sanitation obviously
people need access to um clean water to
to showers to keeping clean there is an
issue around access to health services
we have situations of pregnant and
lactating women children obviously who
need nutritional health
and support and also the psychological
and emotional impact of the crisis the
21 million dollars that irm the
international organization
for migration is appealing for only is
to respond to the urgent need for new
shelter and relocating internally
displaced people from some of the very
difficult and dilapidated settings
they're in to new shelter now iom has in
the last few weeks been able to
relocate around 3 000 families but it is
it is very far from addressing the whole
crisis um earlier in the year in july
iom uh
launched an appeal for around 70 million
uh us dollars and most of the funds that
we need still have not been met
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
northern and western parts will be
largely overcast with outbreaks of rain
in the north west and patchy drizzle and
hill fog elsewhere
eastern britain meanwhile will be mostly
dry with sunny spells it's going to be
warmer than it has been recently but it
will be windy for many the afternoon
will bring little change with northern
and western parts staying dull and damp
into the evening the southwesterly wind
will bring clean air from the atlantic
so the air pollution index where one
means low pollution and 10 means very
high will be low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
taiwan's defence minister says that
china will be ready to mount a
full-scale invasion of the island by
2025.
it comes days after beijing sent around
150 warplanes into the country's air
defense zone an act taiwan says shows
china's continued harassment after more
than 40 years of tensions
national security and foreign policy
analyst arash aramesh joins us on the
programme
lovely to see you this morning and i
wonder if we can start with perhaps the
biggest question in all of this exactly
what is china up to at the moment
uh china has been building up its
military for the past decade china has
had this massive surplus of income this
revenue that has been able to has
enabled china to invest a lot more in
its uh military as you know the chinese
military was always a large military in
terms of numbers alone but numbers alone
don't get you uh
sort of superiority in the battlefield
or in the air or in the oceans you have
to have quality so it's not just
quantity
they've been upping their game in terms
of
quality by
uh developing new fighter jets by
developing new bombers by developing new
uh
enable and air assets
and now it's uh they are showing off and
also threatening
their regional
not ally or nemesis but part of uh
chinese land that they claim to be part
of people's republic of china remember
we're talking about china the people's
republic and then taiwan the republic of
china so uh a country that
seems to claim to be independent a
country that has u.s support so it's
it's it's part of it is also uh it goes
back to sort of these tensions between
taiwan and china but overall
it's a chinese
uh sort of signaling to people to to to
rivals in the south china sea to rivals
in the pacific ocean to ri
rivals in the streets of taiwan that the
chinese military is there is ready and
it's acting aggressively and i think
it's a huge signal to the u.s
administration by the administration and
to our
western countries in the region and
western countries with presence in the
region that china is acting more
aggressively and we have to nip it in
the bottom yeah just on that point then
ah rash i mean as you how close then in
your mind might we come to conflict in
the region as you say the chinese are
behaving very aggressively at the moment
and when you behave aggressively
sometimes mistakes can be made
absolutely i mean don't forget that no
one expected to see
a world war one 1914 to take to take
place after the assassination of the
cousin of the emperor
of the nephew of the emperor no one
expected certain major world you know
events happen or to be of tonkin and so
on and so forth but mistakes do happen
conflicts between major powers the
direct conflict is usually rare the
soviet union and the united states never
fought each other directly it was a cold
war but oh boy was it called known it
wasn't really cold it was hot korea
vietnam afghanistan you name it laos
cambodia of many many different
conflicts in the middle east in latin
america so was it really a cold war
maybe it was called in moscow washington
dc but it certainly wasn't cold across
the globe and so the the problem with
china as china keeps growing and as
china becomes a global power uh the west
and by the west i don't just mean europe
the european countries and the united
states i mean australia i mean japan i
mean south korea countries that have a
common bond and common values and and
share certain western democratic ideals
these countries will have to unite will
have to rise up and we'll have to stand
up against chinese aggression now is it
going to be a war between beijing and
tokyo i doubt it but we can expect a lot
more
conflicts around the world between
superpowers us and china
aramesh i'm afraid we have to leave it
there but thank you so much for giving
user expertise appreciate it
still to come we'll have more on the
backlash to the prime minister's
conference speech yesterday
[Music]